fuir tant qu'il est encore temps ce sont
donc des milliers de civils alors je
vous parle qui ont repris la route
aujourd'hui en ukraine les autorités
ukrainiennes qui annonce la reprise des
évacuations dans plusieurs grandes
villes irvine notamment l'on retrouve
tout de suite notre envoyé spécial cyril
payen bonjour syrie la situation est
toujours extrêmement tendue à ar pin's
et le dernier verrou avant kiev
expliquez-nous ce qui est en train de se
passer
écoutez tous les réseaux
évidemment qu'il ya des opérations en
cours je veux vous dire que vu d'ici
nous sommes là avec jacques avec
exactement ça après leproux qui a été
rabotée par les forces du craignait nous
sommes à quelques centaines de mètres
dire pin est bien difficile d'entendre
parler de corridors humanitaires et
encore moins de treize car nous venons
d'entendre une save bombardements et de
tirs d'artillerie extrêmement violent à
seulement 500 mètres à droite et est en
face de nous c'est à dire ce sont les
faubourgs derby d'îliens devant moi des
dizaines de familles qui ont en rade
courir pour passer ils ont des débuts
tour par les forces des forces
d'autodéfense et rythmes de défense
territoriale évidemment les civils et à
prêter main forte il ya des secouristes
d'ukrainiens et l'armée ukrainienne zee
qui tente de faire à un amarrage cette
visitation tient nettement et qui sait
bien nettement dégradée avec ce qu'on a
pu observer en face en une demi journée
d'hier à demain points à lire puis
nord-ouest de kiev qui a des combats
incessants des bombardements et une
accélération de cet exode des gens qui
continuent de fuir coups de couteau
n'avait raté plusieurs filières des
personnes âgées des blessés ils ont
évacué à travers devant moi et bien ce
qu'ont prises et cette rivière qui passe
ya un pont de fortune en bois qui a été
détruit devant le nombre de jean civatte
on va sur pieds dans l'eau désormais
l'eau et catherine il neige donc ce sont
des conditions de détériore et avec
encore une fois je le répète mon tir
d'artillerie des bombardements convient
d'entendre extrêmement près d'ici donc
évidemment on est très très loin de 2 tu
sais pas s'il n'a pu entendre un
bombardement à l'instant par les
bombardements reprennent donc n'est pas
question de cesser le feu et de
corridors humanitaires là où je me
trouve sur le fond de dire pin à 20
kilomètres le long de 2 km
merci beaucoup ans cyril payen et et
jean geste